this video is sponsored by book Walker
if there's ones on row that seems to be
cursed for anime adaptations it's the
big historical epics berserk Finland
saga vagabonds Kingdom these are the
four pillars of the scene in manga world
people set their profile pictures - in
order to say my taste is better than
your taste and also I have a massive
penis because I am of the superior race
called a manga reader I can't and for
good reason - these are four of the
greatest manga to ever exist yet seem to
be doomed to a cursed life of no anime
adaptation or even worse actually
getting one people were dissatisfied
enough with the first berserk anime that
they tried again two times somehow
getting worse with each attempt and most
people don't even know that Kingdom even
got an anime despite the fact that he
had stunning gorgeous absolutely
breathtaking use of CG so when villain
saga was announced to join the rights of
getting an adaptation everyone had one
important question to determine if this
adaptation was doomed
like the rest does Vinland saga contain
really bad CG I mean it's right but one
of the most critically claims manga of
all time it hasn't been getting as much
attention as one would expect
I'm sure thanks to the seasonal anime
graveyard that is Amazon Prime but as
someone who pimped this title out a few
years ago of course I wants to give a
bit of a spotlight to a source material
I consider to be a masterpiece and an
adaptation that so far seems to be doing
it justice there will be some wild
spoilers for the first four episodes of
the anime at least so there's your
warning but really that just encompasses
the prologue of this tale which is
actually a prologue to a much bigger
tale so really it's just like the
prologue to the prologue villain saga is
fundamentally a revenge story from the
perspective of our main character Thor
ofin who is taken under the wing of his
father's killer ask a lad in his band of
mercenaries his father
Thor's was murdered because one day he
got tired of being in the MCU for so
long he jumped ship and started a new
life in Iceland without fulfilling his
contract obligations and of course
Disney I mean the doms Viking definitely
weren't happy about that Thor ofin
travels with these band of mercenaries
not in spite of his hatred for a scholar
at Bert's because of it as he's been
promised an honorable duel to the death
to get vengeance for his father should
he achieved the various accolades and
more at Pascal at sides if this sounds
like you're getting into an edgy action
fest well you're probably gonna be
disappointed while there are fights the
story itself comes to so much more than
just revenge it's a multi-faceted tale
rich in character unflinching towards
the brutalities of war with a solid
foundation in real history when you
think about historical stories in anime
one name probably springs to mind over
and over again
but unfortunately this is 11th century
Europe in the time of the Vikings and
the Danes invasion of England so I don't
think even Japan can find some
convoluted way to insert him into this
nicely
[ __ ] Sakai him or something but
Finland saga is a story that strictly
operates within that time period in
order to conform to its factual setting
the core narrative itself isn't based on
a true story but everything in the wider
world remains true to history and you
could really feel the author's passion
for the setting and time periods when
reading the manga I often found myself
looking up what kings and Wars were
mentioned and sure enough they were all
factually accurate hell even a good
chunk for the characters in the show are
just straight-up people from history
Leif Erikson Prince Knud Kings Swain and
even Thor ofin himself all existed in
that time period and other characters
like Oscar lad are individuals based on
Norse folklore very few liberties are
taken with the facts in the series and
having all this historical context just
add so much credibility to the
characters and the world even when you
do have someone like the brick [ __ ]
outside this Thor Kell casually
eating a single i'ts with enough force
to make a kebab out of five guys that's
five people not five greasy burgers it
pushes the boundary of what's possible
just enough for you to accept but some
of these larger-than-life characters
existed in our real world history which
is technically true but this is
important because it adds a sense of
legitimacy to their actions and the
events that take place in the world they
inhabit this adds real weight to the
stories that are told because a great
deal of what these people do can be
really hard to swallow some of what's
shown can be heavier than the things you
see in berserk or Game of Thrones
because everything is soaked in an air
of realism there is no veil of fantasy
to avert your eyes of the atrocities
that you see there is no clear divide
between right and wrong and good and bad
everything's just portrayed as a part of
life a part of history
nothing is romanticized and through this
brutal unflinching lens you get reminded
that sometimes reality can be far more
unforgiving than the world of
imagination the only thing that's
potentially weird about the historical
setting at least than the anime is how
the language barrier is portrayed
because everything is spoken in Japanese
so you have awkward seems like a kid
who's speaking Japanese which is meant
to be Nordic ask him some Frenchman if
there's anyone who speaks Nordic who
replies in Japanese which is meant to be
French that they don't understand what
he's saying despite the fact that both
speaking Japanese and then there's Thor
Kel can speak English and Nordic which
is both spoken as Japanese so you don't
know when the Englishman is speaking - I
suppose speaking fees about what he's
saying but sometimes he speaks Nordic -
lot of people and sometimes he speaks
English the English people it's all
spoken in Japanese all my god dear Lord
I never thought I'd say this but would
it be too much trouble to hear some good
old-fashioned English I can't the
speaker English though while the
historical aspect is a nice additional
touch the heart of this series is of
course the writing and characters and
I'm glad to say this is some of the best
character development you can find
anywhere there is enough depth and each
character presented to warrant a
full-blown character study that I can't
possibly fit in this one video though
what I can focus on is one of the most
interesting character dynamics you can
find here which of course is that
between Thoreau Finn and Oskar lat on
the surface Thor ofin seems pretty
one-dimensional his singular linear goal
of wanting to win ask lads favor enough
to be rewarded with a duel is basically
all he bangs on about but it's what you
see him struggle with in silence that
makes it interesting otherwise him being
a moody teenager certain revenge
basically means he just be Viking Sasuke
[Music]
seeing thora fan go from this sweet boy
to an emotional killer is actually kind
of heartbreaking in so many other shows
this could so easily divulge into an
edge fest buts here you just feel sad
it's tragic to see such a joyful kid
turn into a pure ball of anger and
hatred despite all of his dad's best
efforts in his last moments to teach him
to literally do the opposite of
everything he's doing now
my knee took another we night internal
session you are king although you don't
know it's kind of reminiscent to how
Kratos tried to teach his son and God of
boy except Kratos truly did give up his
weapons for a life of pacifism and boy
actually had a name the development of
Thor offends lust for revenge doesn't
pay off until far later in the story
though meaning that the star of this
story arc being adapted in the anime is
undoubtedly
oskol at asclad is foreign beyond the
best antagonists in anime this year and
it's not even close
he's a cunning scheming manipulative man
who pays away for absolutely atrocious
acts and yet it's ngayon impossible to
hate him he just has this witty charm
and charisma that's incredibly
infectious you believe he's the leader
of a mercenary gang not because the
story says so but because you yourself
can find yourself thinking man what a
[ __ ] Africa Chad I'd bloody follow
you into battle his relationship with
Thor ofin is complicated to say the
least because nothing speaks daddy
issues like being raised by the man who
killed your bloody daddy but it's never
explicitly stated how asked aloud views
the boy
one moment he can treat him like a
complete tool to be manly play to the
news being like hey laddie you remember
that one time I killed your dad haha
yeah as well bats wasn't it yet other
times it can seem like he does actually
care about him perhaps stemming from his
deep respect of Thor's he plays mentor
and his the closest thing for a friend
has to a guardian who's raising him up
because despite being a manipulative
[ __ ] you have to respect how wise and
cunning years
you mean they learn you cannot do it
this is just a slice in what is a series
rich with complicated characters who
develop through the course of the story
from the rise of Prince Knut to Thor
Kell being far more introspective than
the war loving bruty initially seems to
be to all the other side characters who
are just there to drink a shit-ton
apparently a little bit of the bubbly
and the role they all play in the saga
that unfolds is just so perfectly
intertwined with the smaller stories and
messages the series explores because
like the characters the story has layers
remember in goblin slayer when the
goblins did a bad thing and people were
shocked that the goblins did a bad thing
in the series show the bad thing well I
find it funny that the world of villain
saga is one just as brutal that doesn't
shy away from showing it and somehow
there's a sense of beauty in the
storytelling gear the thing that hits
you hardest isn't the shock of seeing
the raping murdering and pillaging that
it is a part of daily life it's a son so
far off the path his father desperately
tried to teach him it's a kind mother
being betrayed for showing love and
compassion to a stranger
it's a priest teaching the war loving
Vikings about love they're the types of
stories that pierce the soul and sticks
with you far after the episode or
chapter ends and I think that's the best
way I can describe the writing in this
series it's not some dramatic roller
coaster full of nothing but thrills it's
just powerful it's raw it's full of
moments that feel so heavy moments that
penetrate so deeply that you often feel
the need to stop at the end of an
episode or chapter just to be taken
aback by what's happened and bask in
what you've just experienced it's a grim
tale but one that's oddly beautiful and
optimistic in its outlook every so often
you come across a work of fiction that
seems to have an air of prestige
surrounding it something that goes
beyond character development or story
arcs or themes or art or animation but
something that makes it just that much
more special and though there may be
other shows you enjoy more or series you
relate to better or anime or manga that
are superior on a technical level
there's some kind of unquantifiable
quality you can't quite put your finger
on there mesas
and above the rest but you can feel it
in the moments it's that sense of
immeasurable greatness I felt it the
first time I read berserk when I caved
in to watch legend of the Galactic
Heroes when I closed the final page of
now Chios hours monster and certainly
when I was able to first experience
Vinland saga this is a manga that
doesn't come along very often and one
even rarer because his adaptation is
doing a great job so far with it he
might not be the widely appealing hype
machine that saccharine titanal demon
slayer is right now but it's a tale that
will leave a deep impression on those
who choose to experience it it's not the
type of story people just watched and
forgets about it's one that will leave
an imprint on you long after you finish
it that years later you'll look back on
it and think wow this was something
truly special
hey guys hope you enjoyed that thank you
very much to book walker for sponsoring
this video all of the available Vinland
saga volumes are available to buy on
book walk of right now and though the
anime is doing a fantastic job you would
really be doing yourself a disservice if
you completely ignore the manga because
i do think it's a freaking masterpiece
right now there is a sale going on and
the entire series is almost 50% off so
there is no better time to get it this
sale lasts until the 24th of September
so take advantage of it while you can if
you sure you want to stay anime only but
still want to take advantage of this say
oh you can preemptively bye from vol 5
onwards which is where I think the anime
is gonna end links in the description if
you want to get it and also use coupon
code giggle for five dollars off your
first purchase anyway that's it for me
I've been gig ugh and I'll see you all
next time